– Hallo! Oh, Entschuldigung!
Wartest du schon lange?
– Na ja. Wir haben noch Zeit.
Warmen Tee?
– Oh, danke schön.
Ich bin in letzter Zeit ziemlich gestresst,
weil einige Kollegen krank sind.
– Wirklich nur in letzter Zeit? Wie lange
willst du das eigentlich noch machen?
Ich finde, du solltest einfach mal
weniger arbeiten.
Du könntest auch mal Nein sagen. Hm?
– Mhm.
– Ja, ich bin heute auch gestresst
wegen dem Termin.
Ich weiß immer noch nicht,
ob ich das Kind überhaupt will.
Sebastian meint, ich muss mich
endlich entscheiden.
– Das stimmt.
Aber zum hundertsten Mal, Nina:
Du schaffst das!
Du kannst auch … du kannst auch eine
Beratung machen. Vielleicht hilft dir das.
– Okay.
Aber nur, wenn du einen Yoga-Kurs machst,
um etwas gegen deinen Stress zu tun.
– Nur, wenn du mitkommst.
– Lisa, du bist auch nur ein Mensch.
Vergiss das nicht, ja?
– Ja.
– Apropos Mensch: Da ist einer in deinem
Bauch, der heute untersucht werden soll.
Oh, das …
– Ja, ist okay. Lass uns einfach reingehen
und dann schauen wir weiter, ja?
– Ja. Ich … ich wollte nicht …